même la présidente la première ministre
des messieurs les ministres
de commission mes chers collègues
quelle prise avons-nous aujourd'hui sur
le conflit en Ukraine si ce n'est par
notre responsabilité des tas membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies cette responsabilité nous
oblige face à cette résurgence de
l'impérialisme russe et face à cette
guerre de conquête guerre réactionnaire
par essence
il est de notre responsabilité
collective de lutter contre cette fuite
en avant de Poutine ensemble nous devons
arrêter ce torrent de violation du droit
international de crime de guerre voire
de crimes contre l'humanité
référendum dans les régions occupées
annexion de quatre régions ukrainiennes
menace d'une nucléarisation de la guerre
mobilisation partielle l'escalade se
confirme jour après jour avec le
sentiment que la diplomatie
internationale est un puissante et pour
cause le désordre des relations
internationales interroge notre capacité
d'action surtout lorsque l'on évoque la
crédibilité des États dioxydantaux et
des alliés de l'OTAN organisation sortie
elle aussi d'un autre âge au sein de
notre communauté internationale
comment entraîner une vague de
solidarité et de condamnation contre la
Russie lorsque les États-Unis la France
et d'autres ont passé 30 ans à mettre à
feu et à sang le Moyen-Orient et
l'Afrique prenant tant de liberté avec
le droit international la Libye la
Palestine l'Afghanistan l'Irak le Sahel
mais aussi le font monétaire
international la Banque mondiale
l'époque n'oublie pas les attaques les
reniements et les trahisons la géométrie
variable des engagements des pays riches
et le poison qui a détruit la confiance
des peuples dans les Nations Unies et
dans le droit international c'est la
raison pour laquelle on ne peut pas
s'étonner de la tiédeur du soutien
international notamment des pays les
plus fragiles aux résolutions proposées
par les États-Unis et leurs alliés sur
l'Ukraine les pays du Sud n'acceptent
plus de s'aligner systématiquement sur
une Bastille qui les observe du haut de
ses remparts le président français ne
semble pas l'avoir compris lui qui a
préféré accuser à la tribune des Nations
Unies la semaine dernière des
partenaires indispensables à la
recherche de la paix je le cite ceux qui
se taisent aujourd'hui servent malgré
eux et secrètement avec une certaine
complicité la cause d'un nouvel
impérialisme d'un cynisme contemporain
qui désagrège notre ordre international
sur lequel la paix n'est possible fin de
citation avec ses discours accusateurs
les mots ont perdu leur sens pour
beaucoup les termes comme démocratie et
d'humanitaire ou droits de l'homme
prononcé par le camp occidental ne
veulent plus rien dire ils ont trop
souvent été synonyme d'intervention
militaire ou financière
mais ne nous y trompons pas Vladimir
Poutine a compris cette faiblesse et
tente de créer un contrepoids en créant
une hégémonie reposant sur un
nationalisme exacerbé et sur la force
brute son ordre mondial est fondé sur
des valeurs de n de la démocratie de
mépris des peuples et de violation des
libertés élémentaires comme le droit du
travail et la liberté d'expression la
liberté de manifestation ou encore de la
presse
ces deux camps sont détestés par tous
les états qui observent ce triste
spectacle pendant que chez eux les
famines se multiplient la montée des
eaux menaces et les guerres nourries par
l'appétit du capital font rage en
silence car n'oublions pas toutes les
autres guerres actuelles le Sahel
Arménie le Congo Kinshasa le Sarah
occidental l'Éthiopie et j'en passe les
autorités et les médias les ignorent
comme elles n'impacte puisqu'elle
n'impacte pas la vie quotidienne des
Européens et des Français d'autres
débats ne sont-ils se sont-ils déjà
tenus dans cette hémicycle à propos de
guerre où nous nous sommes pas
directement belligérant quoique
cette guerre pose les questions de la
mondialisation de la souveraineté de
l'Europe et de la France à travers
l'énergie l'alimentation l'industrie et
le choc qu'elle crée dans notre société
est terrible mais il le sera d'autant
plus pour les plus précaires si nous
n'agissons pas pour agir il y a les
leviers des politiques publiques mon
groupe est la nupes dans son ensemble
seront là pour vous proposer des
amendements visant à améliorer le projet
de loi de finance en ce sens mais sans
obtenir la paix en Ukraine rien ne sera
possible et pour l'obtenir que peut
faire un pays membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
comme la France il faut prouver la
volonté de notre état à soutenir le camp
de la paix coûte que coûte et c'est là
que l'urgence réside pour cela madame la
ministre changer radicalement de
diplomatie
les députés du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine ne cessent de
le dire pour allier les États membres
des Nations Unies contre la guerre en
Russie il faut retrouver l'humilité nous
devons plus être ce pays qui vend des
armes aux tortionnaires et obélixérant
pour des milliards d'euros par an ni
être ce pays disposant de l'arme
nucléaire et qui refusent comme les
autres de la démanteler définitivement
nous ne devons plus être non plus ce
pays qui donne des leçons à tout va
alors qu'il n'est pas capable de
respecter lui-même le droit
international sur son sol pensant à
l'île de Mayotte que la France a arraché
des Comores pour son propre intérêt en
violation de la Charte des Nations Unies
la France a encore un très grand travail
pour changer pour abandonner la course
aux intérêts économiques en prenant le
chemin de l'universalité du droit
car c'est le seul chemin à emprunter
pour retrouver une crédibilité et une
légitimité au sein du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies et pour
gagner la paix il nous faut devenir ce
pays qui se tient aux côtés de tous les
peuples qui souffrent et qui et qui
combattent pour l'application de leurs
droits légitime alors souveraineté
territoriale le peuple ukrainien lutte
par les armes pour sa liberté et pour
préserver cette souveraineté comme c'est
autorisé par l'article 51 de la Charte
des Nations Unies qui dit il faut leur
rappeler ici qu'aucune disposition de la
prise en charge ne porte atteinte au
droit naturel de légitime défense
individuelle ou collective dans le cas
où un membre des Nations Unies à l'objet
d'une agression armée jusqu'à ce que le
Conseil de sécurité ait pris des mesures
nécessaires pour maintenir la paix et la
sécurité internationale
pour trouver la paix possible le courage
n'est donc pas militaire il doit être
diplomatique l'important c'est de poser
des jalons d'un dialogue comme cela
était le cas pour l'initiative
céréalières de la mer Noire grâce aux
Nations Unies depuis le premier août un
couloir a été aménagé dans la mer Noire
auprès après après des négociations avec
les belligérants entre les belligérants
plus d'une centaine de navires battant
pavillon nusiens qui transporte des
millions de tonnes de blés Ukrainiens
sont escortés par la marine russe pour
être déchargée notamment en Afrique de
l'Est ou la famine menace des dizaines
de millions de personnes cet exemple
d'optimisme réaliste a été pris par le
Secrétaire national le secrétaire
général pardon des Nations Unies lors de
son discours d'ouverture de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies il voulait
démontrer à travers cet exemple que des
solutions existent si les diplomaties
discutent même contre vents et marées
depuis 2014 et l'annexion de la Crimée
ukrainienne par la Russie le Parti
communiste français appelle à une
conférence européenne pour la paix et la
sécurité sous l'égide des Nations Unies
cette étape serait essentielle pour
repenser et apaiser les relations
internationales à l'est de l'Union
européenne et pour prendre en compte les
aspirations des peuples qu'ils soient
Ukrainiens polonais biélorus ou russe
l'Ukraine devra retrouver son territoire
souverain et un violet tandis que les
responsables russes au premier rang
desquels Vladimir Poutine devront payer
pour leurs crimes aucun peuple ne devra
payer l'addition de la victoire ou de la
défaite seuls les profits de guerre ou
qu'ils soient devront être
réquisitionnés pour financer la
reconstruction
cette paix juste respectera la
résistance héroïque du peuple ukrainien
qui meurt et qui souffre au quotidien
cette paix respectera le peuple russe
elle lui permettra d'en finir avec la
conscription et avec la terrible
répression du Kremlin sur son peuple le
groupe de la Gauche démocrate est
républicaine envoie sa totale solidarité
à ces femmes c'est à ces hommes qui
luttent de part et d'autre de la
frontière ukrainienne au péril de leur
vie pour voir cette situation se
terminer et qui tiennent tête par leur
bravoure au Kremlin de nombreux
militants de la paix en Ukraine et en
Russie risque leur vie pour témoigner de
ce qu'ils vivent ce sont eux qui
permettront une réconciliation entre les
peuples pour anéantir le risque d'un
éternel recommencement ce dont les
Français et les Allemands peuvent
témoigner
comme le dit le responsable du mouvement
pacifique ukrainien que peut-être vous
avez rencontré à l'occasion de vos
voyages je le cite mettre fin à la
guerre passe par la réconciliation
mettre en avant des valeurs de paix et
de justice un mouvement mondial pour la
paix pourraient changer cela en
préconisant un cesser le feu des portes
entre l'Est et l'Ouest ainsi qu'entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine le discours de paix
est souillé aujourd'hui les militants
anti-guerre et les objecteurs de
conscience au service militaire sont
persécutés mais aucun appétit pour la
gloire et les profits tirés de
l'effusion de sang ne changera le fait
que la paix et non la guerre est une
norme de la vie humaine fin de citation
il était bon de donner la parole au
pacifiste ukrainien je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]